we've got labour's shadow work and
pension secretary johnson reynolds
on the programme i'm not sure how much
of that you managed to catch but we just
saw a film
showing the impact of school closures on
young people and many struggling to get
the technology
they need anxiety worry about not
getting the grades they
deserve at what point do you think
schools need to reopen
it was an incredibly powerful film i did
just
hear it and credit to those young people
for speaking to you so candidly
the way that they did that is why we
wanted to keep schools open
as long as possible unfortunately the
department of education didn't take the
steps
necessary to keep them open for longer
but you know to hear young people
describe how they still haven't got
access to technology haven't got access
to
broadband at this stage of the pandemic
is inexcusable clearly to answer your
question directly schools can only go
back
when the health factors are such that
they allow them to go back but there is
no excuse
for the government not acting to make
sure people have technology
and access to online learning at home
none whatsoever it's difficult isn't it
because
looking forward you say that schools can
only go back when the health
factors allow them to go back my
question i guess is
what does that actually mean i mean
labor you know you're in a position
where
you have been criticized i guess for
calling for things that are going to
happen anyway you know this is a chance
to kind of set out a road map
at what point do you think schools
should be able to go back
what's your roadmap for that to happen
it will depend on the rollout of the
vaccination program it will depend on
the infection rates in each area and it
will depend on the state or the nhs and
whether it's on the brink of being
overwhelmed as it is
in many parts of the country you know
there are things
that the government can't control about
the pandemic but there is lots that they
can control
and the response from government to
situations like this but also to what
we're talking about
on monday in poland in terms of
universal credit and the support given
to people
who have to be at home who can't work
these are things the government can do
you can't get away from the fact that we
have suffered in the uk
the highest death toll in europe and
the biggest recession of any major
economy
that comes down to how the government
has responded to it so they've got to be
scrutinized for that
and how we get schools back will depend
on how they take decisions now
like the one we're asking them to take
tomorrow you mentioned that the decision
on
universal credit i know something you're
keen to talk about on your brief of
course so in april the 20 pound a week
boost to
universal credit is due to end rishi
soon at the chancellor wants to give
families a 500 pound one-off payment
instead
is that enough no i mean i'm glad you've
raised that because that is quite
frankly
a terrible policy first of all if you go
ahead with this cut
you are reducing out of work support
unemployment benefits
to their lowest real terms level since
1992
at a time when unemployment is about to
peak
but of course the reason a one-off
payment is a bad policy is
whilst we're talking about six million
families being affected those families
will change throughout the years and
we'll go
back into works and we'll come out we've
had at times of the pandemic
two hundred 000 new claimants coming
onto the system in a single month so a
one-off payment a snapshot
completely fails to support those people
there is simply
no reason that this cut should take
place in april
it's the wrong thing for families i mean
a thousand pounds a year
is like your gas your electric your
broadband bill all rolled in together
but it's also the wrong thing for the
economy that is six billion pounds of
spending
being taken out of the economy at a time
when we need it the most frankly so the
priority for us
is to secure the economy protect the nhs
and then rebuild the country and to do
that
parliament has to do the right thing
tomorrow and conservative mps of course
due to abstain on that and opposition
database non-binding
i guess my question as well to you is
labour's position
as i understand it is that universal
credit should be scrapped
in the middle of a pandemic is that the
right priority still when we talk about
scrapping universal credit
that's about our priorities for the next
parliament and the election manifesto
that we will stand on
there are huge problems with universal
credit it's not just labour mps who
recognize that
that people see the five-week weight the
impact of the two-child limit
the sanctions the conditionality the the
treatment of disabled people
in the system the treatment of child
care which is always
has to be paid up front yet universal
credit is paid in arrears
i can't ignore those real problems so i
have to come up with a system
much more comprehensive much more
effective than universal credit as it
stands and that's exactly what i
intend to do but for now for what needs
to happen
this week and this year there is a vote
tomorrow in parliament to cancel
that cut of a thousand pounds a year for
six million
british families there is no question
that parliament should do the right
thing
and vote to cancel that could are you
talking to conservatives
about it are you expecting a rebellion
there i can't predict what conservative
colleagues
will do but yes people have been in
touch there's been some productive
conversations look when was the last
government
to cut out of work benefits in
a major economic downturn i think you
have to go back to the great depression
and the national government to find that
there is a reason this never happens
there is a reason it is not in the
national interest it is absolutely
the wrong priority for the government to
even be considering doing this
should even be a vote on this tomorrow
the government should have made a
decision on this a long
time ago rather than wait till the last
minute as they always seem to do
in the pandemic yes lots of conservative
colleagues are equally
worried about this and i hope they will
vote with how they
really feel about this and therefore
parliament will make the right decision
i guess it's only right for me to put
you know a bit of the conservative
perspective here because we're all
talking about a fact that they've given
a temporary boost to universal credit
during the pandemic
and there is of course this uh 500 pound
one-off payment
instead too now you've been very
critical of
the government on universal credit on
schools
at the same time though over 3.5 million
first doses
of the vaccine have been given out
that's more than any other european
country is it time to hold your hands up
and say actually you know what on this
the government done a really good job
well i've seen the the vaccine roll out
in my constituency and it's brilliant to
see it's affirming
we want the vaccine rollout to succeed
and we want to be the first country
to vaccinate all those vulnerable groups
and i think the whole country
feels that way the problem with the
government is they they like
international comparisons on the things
that they feel they're doing well on
when it comes to tragically the death
toll or the impact on the economy
they're a bit more reticent about it so
they've got to understand that when we
hold them to account
it's because we want the national
strategy on this pandemic to succeed we
want to
scrutinize them not to score points
against them but to make the country's
national response
more effective and if you think about
this vote on universal credit and
working tax credit
tomorrow you know clearly we talked
about that to tackle this better if we
make the right decision honestly so
we've got to win a lot we've spoken a
lot about the vote um
tomorrow uh to be fair and mr reynolds i
am quite keen to talk about some other
issues um
as well and the government's decided to
tighten up border restrictions
in light of these new variants now we've
all seen the images of
instagram influencers going on holiday
posting beach
or poolside snaps if you go on holiday
right now you being selfish
sorry i missed that last bit uh sophie
but i think you were talking about
the restrictions on airports and
travelers coming into the country
i just don't understand why it's taking
so long to put those arrangements in
place we've seen what went on
in other countries and i think we were
told initially that those just weren't
effective they weren't worth doing
but clearly they are so i don't
understand why it's taken so long i
think there is a significant degree of
national concern
about why we've been so slow to make
sure our borders are secure and we're
stopping new strains coming into the
country
is there some personal responsibility to
hear though as well
are you being selfish if you go on
holiday now
well it obviously depends the
circumstances about which you are
traveling but yes i mean let's be clear
though people have
in the main throughout this pandemic
abided by some really tough
restrictions yes we all know some high
profile infringements that have taken
place but people have
not seen family members they've been
students away from home who haven't been
able to go home
and see their family so let's not try
and let the government
get away with blaming the public or
blaming people for their personal
conduct for
where the pandemic response has gone
wrong i think that lets them off the
hook
the majority of british people have
abided by really tough restrictions
and they've done it in the national
interest and they've done it whatever
the personal cost to them
has been and we have to recognize that
one thing that it does seem people
perhaps not always obeying the rules are
on is the
quarantine or on self-isolating some of
the surveys showing pretty low number of
people
who have been in south isolating for the
full amount of time given that
do you think people should be put in
hotels quarantine hotels like they do in
other countries
if they return to the uk from abroad
if that is the most effective way uh to
tackle that i i'd look at that i'm not
sure necessarily it is
the case i mean i think most people do
abide by the restrictions
have been able to stay at home if
there's a specific court i've seen
things that look like they may have
worked
quite successfully in other countries so
there's best practice there but again
the problem is sophie we're behind the
curve on this we haven't
acted quickly enough we haven't done
what other countries have done so
there's plenty of things
that we can learn from but as i say i
think most people have abided by some
tough restrictions whatever the personal
cost to them